and we're seeing the queen delivering a
check but
you cannot capture that night because of
dave as david mentioned there is a
threat against the rook
and that is why dubois rajabov has
sidestepped with the rook
and everything to play for material
versus king safety dynamics oh
i really do enjoy this type of chest
because if dubois
can survive and rekeep the extra port
then he will be winning
yes actually both sides their kings look
relatively safe right now
so who will get at the opponent's king
first which pawns will be stronger
i'm struggling to um pick a side i mean
for example i love my pawns but black's
pieces those long range pieces the black
queen the black bishop the black rook
they're all
controlling so many squares right now um
this one i think rajabov has his chances
but the clock situation
it might be critical for him um white
meanwhile he needs to do something about
that night now
yeah the clock situation is super
worrying because white has two
minutes just under two and a half
minutes black has just 30 seconds
that is not enough to play good chess in
such a sharp position
and okay dubois has protected the night
and i'm expecting the queen to suddenly
start to
dash in this would be the first move
that i'm going to go in because you want
to play the most aggressive move
possible
and i want the queen to deep dive into
the white position and just
attack the king but at the same time get
going with that pawn that is
three squares away from promoting
rajpov meanwhile going under five
seconds there
he made a move with three seconds left
okay he didn't choose it he didn't see
it maybe
yeah i agree with jovanka bringing
black's queen deep into the heart of
white's position
that would have been a strong one but he
goes for the more natural move maybe the
most obvious move pushing that black
pawn forward
eleven seconds left eight seconds seven
six
oh this is getting nervous he has to
make a move he's got three seconds on
the clock come on
we're okay one second left
when he made that move timor raj above
he's getting nervous i think we're
getting nervous here in the studio
black though playing a good move
bringing the black queen towards the
white king
um white's king i mentioned it was safe
but it is slightly airy
that pawn in front of white's king
actually um a couple
a couple of squares in front of it it
wants to be back going backwards right
now to keep that king nice and safe
it does mean that black's queen has
targets on that right side of the board
black not only has that strong born in
the middle the king the white king is
also becoming a target
yeah and i think with a with rajabov
just having 11 seconds on the clock
this is the moment for dubois to just
introduce chaos into the position
i really hope that he starts involving
his knight
and just asking some questions to
rajabov
yeah the white knight right now um it's
looking nice and pretty
but it's not doing anything it's hitting
thin air it needs to re-centralize
itself knights are much better in the
center of the board
that white knight it should go to the
center right next to the white queen
um and it needs to start attacking that
black pawn in the middle
um it's not so easy though there's so
much going on in this position dubov
also dropping low on time um he's on the
defensive
he's not used to this type of situation
simon mentioned it earlier he's out of
his comfort zone he wants to be
attacking he wants to be sacrificing
stuff
here he's actually got the extra pawn
but he's on the defensive
um duboff maybe not in familiar
territory
and he's spending a lot of time under a
minute now for daniel dubo in the game
where he
has to win to tie the first semi-final
match and yeah
well teamwork with only 11 seconds he
only needs a draw though
yes he only needs a draw and uh it's
looking
like an incredibly wild position as
david mentioned
if white centralizes the night there's
absolutely everything to play for though
the margin of error is
incredibly high in that position what is
wildness now the position or donald
dubose here
both are pretty well i like it though i
like the uh disheveled look yeah i know
i don't like though is how much time
he's been spending on this move he's
spent two minutes
he's got 20 seconds left and this allows
rajabov
to reach and he's done it he's made the
move that we wanted him to play
he has centralized the knights to attack
the pawn and now
rajabov has gone with a deep dive into
with the queen
into the left side of the board yeah the
problem for dubov is that not only did
he spend two minutes there he gave
rajabov two minutes to think on his own
this is just too passive you cannot put
your rook on such a square
when you need to attack and uh like
yeah black's queen now zooming across
he's attacking a pawn
he's attacking a pawn um which maldana
dubois has defended with his queen
um the white queen there trying to
attack the black rook which is defended
right now trying to protect a pawn
just in front of white's king um there's
no threats there's just no threat you
can just push the pawn
yeah so ivanka is looking for black's
pawn in the middle there to just
keep pushing and rajabov he finds it
that black pawn you mentioned it you
called it six seven moves ago he's gonna
decide the game
um black now has a few options white is
trying to capture that pawn with his
knight i mean
this is really tense now rajabov i think
he has it for one second
okay he's just made a move he did he's
made the move that i was wondering
myself
is it possible to play this bishop move
and he did it
he made a spectacular move sacrificing
his bishop he made it with one second
left
he was just judging up he was weighing
up the risk there
um and white captures that bishop with
the queen he couldn't have captured with
the pawn it would have allowed checkmate
and timor rajabov has made a new queen
we saw three queens on the board there
temporarily that queen was captured
um both queens now i mean rajabov he
will not lose this game
surely black having this rook for
white's knight and two pawns but white's
knight in two pawns they're not doing
anything right now they're off on the
other side of the board
it's all about the white king rajabov
he's winning this position
he just needs a draw as well surely he's
going to guide this home
yeah he has to guide it home look the
key for him is actually probably not to
swap off queens
the white king is very very unsafe if he
swaps with queens the king
the white king will be super safe and uh
yeah
that's why you see him not do that he's
refused to exchange a queen instead
he's just determined to make the white
king
life a little bit unpleasant yeah some
white queen
now trying to attack the black rook um
dubov he knows he needs a bit of a
miracle here
to win this game he's hoping that
rajabov doesn't see that threat maybe
but black's rook it can step forward um
it can
yeah as long as rajabov does not lose
his rook here
he's still in control and he uses his
rook to join up with his queen
the black rook and the black queen now
penetrated the enemy
um enemy camp he's looking for checkmate
as black but he's going to allow a
repetition of moves he knows he's
winning as black but he's allowing white
to repeat
to keep checking his king because he
knows the draw is enough yes
well daniel dubo is deciding if he wants
to do that
i guess there's no hope for him now
other than a mile slip the best one i
can go for is a draw
that would eliminate him well it would
not eliminate him it would mean that he
loses today's match as well it means he
really needs to come out fighting
tomorrow
yeah definitely we need to see a change
of approach because we saw
rajabov has been supreme on this and
this is why
dubois goes well and mile will just play
on a muzzle just put my knight into the
center of the board
because it doesn't matter a draw is the
same as a loss
yes and um white's knight now in the
center of the board i think rajabov
should be winning if he brings his rook
across
to give check white's king now out in
the open no shelter
um all black needs to do is start
coordinating again his queen and his
rook to continue giving checks
i expect to see a check here with
black's queen um
rajabov he does have options and the
first time we've seen him frown today
really
um he's getting a bit nervous he knows
he's winning but he knows the game the
longer it continues
um the longer maybe daniel dubois
holds these chances uh meanwhile rajabov
so calm just taking that pawn
um i would have gone straight for
white's king but he grabs that black
pawn
uh so he grabs the white pawn um with
his queen
he's just struggling his only hope now
is to create some kind of checkmate
against the black king but
he just can't do it um there's just not
enough pieces not enough ammunition left
and it actually doesn't matter
in terms of score what kind of score
roger buff gets if he wins the match it
doesn't matter it's two and a half
points one and a half points or
two and a half three and a half tomorrow
if dubois wins two and a half points
that doesn't matter you know
it all that counts is that they've tied
the match yeah good point
game points are irrelevant so yup that's
a nice move
by dubois and now we have a check and
the
the king goes up the ball so many
spartan kings today
no fear marching up the board but this
is a very risky strategy because the
queens are
on the board and uh now the queen has
given a check and the king is all alone
there is no one to help it so it has to
move
yeah and that white king has to i think
it has to step back
if it steps forward um it will get
checkmated okay it steps across
instead rajabov now can use his rook to
capture a pawn yeah he's done it
he has done it he looked very surprised
by dubos decision dubov
kind of flinching there he knows the end
is nigh white is so tied up that
the white knight is actually pinned he
can't even move right now so rajabov has
a move to do anything he wants pretty
much
um this game is a complete draw um the o
well at the very best sorry for duboff
um
the best he can hope for is a draw yeah
and uh
he keeps running down his clock just to
keep us all on our toes
yeah yeah he's played that move with
five seconds left on the clock
and uh okay now i now i think he has it
in the bag
it just has to give a few checks and it
is going to be game
over for djibout yeah rajabov just kind
of stroking his chin there he knows
there's no more chances white's king
right in the center of the board now
right in the middle there and that's a
flashy check from black the white
knight cannot take the black queen
because it is pinned the queens are
about to be traded and daniel dubois he
actually resigns he didn't even get the
draw in that game he resigns
it is over and that means timor jabo is
the winner of the first semi-final match
against
daniel dubo